valerian almost had the best opera in cs
go history join its competitive scene we
were this close to having kenny s on a
pro-valorant team last week nell
reported that kenny was on trial for o.g
valerant and was very close to signing
with the team which could have seen him
compete in the valorant french regional
league and kenny all but confirmed this
news in his most recent youtube video
yes i was about to join og varun team so
yes the leak were true i was supposed to
play professional value unfortunately
for kenny riot didn't allow the move
because of contractual issues this could
be the same issue that plagued nbk while
he transitioned to valerian exactly at
the time when there was the whole
circuit that was going on some of the
teams to make changes it was pretty
complicated but alas kenny s and valerie
joins the long list of esports could
have been where do you want to see kenny
s ballarant cs go rocket league